all right a little game of what happens
first on this thursday edition of pftpm
reminder we've got eric decosta coming
up in about 15 minutes or so what
happens first three of the quarterbacks
taken in round one last thursday night
trey lance justin fields mac jones who
starts first
i think it's trey lance and it's funny
because i there are arguments to be made
for all three of those guys but i feel
like with trey lance he'll probably
start first a because he was picked
first b because the 49ers had to give up
so much to go get him and then also
because you've got a qb that would be in
front of him and jimmy garoppolo that's
scheduled to make about 25 million
dollars most of that is not guaranteed
so even though jed york is saying yeah
we're willing to pay that and you know
if trey lance doesn't start for another
couple years we're okay with that
i i don't know how much i believe that i
just feel like there's gonna be either
internal external pressure whatever it
is to see trey lance to show that they
got it right and i think trey lance will
start first of those guys
i agree with you and i feel like the
heart of the 49ers try to convince us
that
they really would keep jimmy garoppolo
for two years and make a 50 million
dollar investment i.e the money that
they will pay garoppolo in allowing
lance to develop after you gave up all
that to go get him i just don't see it
happening now
i i i think i i'm gonna agree with you
and say lance i thought about fields but
remember when they did this four years
ago with trubisky
and mike glennon was the starter glennon
actually did start the first four games
but i think there's a good chance justin
fields is the week one starter because
they gave up a lot to move up to get
justin fields and if fields can beat out
andy dalton what the hell were you doing
giving up all that to go get him the one
guy that i don't think will start week
one is mack jones i think it'll be cam
newton barring some sort of an injury i
think mac jones will be on the bench all
right
sam darnold in carolina or zach wilson
his replacement in new york wins a
division title what happens first
uh i would say zach wilson mainly
because i'm not sure that sam darnold is
going to be a starting quarterback after
this year and who knows where he's going
to be because it might not be in
carolina look i think carolina is really
on this huge quest to get a franchise
quarterback and we don't know if sam
darwin's gonna be that guy he certainly
could be but i think it's worth noting
that he still had the worst passer
rating among the 35 qualified passers
out of the entire league okay so that's
worse than carson wentz and drew lock
and cam newton and all these guys that
we said we're not good passers nick
mullins is even on that list so i just
feel like by virtue of elimination of
sam darnold it's probably going to be
zach wilson but that division obviously
is very tough mike
i think you you you make a good point
and sam darnold is only going to win a
division
most likely in 2022 if the team that he
signs to serve as a backup wins the
division because panthers buccaneers
saints falcons going to be a hard time
even if the panthers are better than
they were last year so zack wilson we
know is going to have multiple
opportunities with the jets although who
knows maybe at the end of the day it'll
only be three just like it was for sam
darnold all right what happens
first tom brady retires or aaron rodgers
retires
i love this question because like if you
had asked me this a year ago i would
have said obviously tom brady but now
man i don't know
i think i probably think that it will be
tom brady but like
at this point i'm not putting playing
pass like 50 past tom brady i i don't
know what he's gonna do he just seems to
defy all logic and all sense of father
time so you know i'm gonna go weird and
i'm just gonna say aaron rodgers why not
um
i still think it's gonna be brady
and i think at some point father time is
gonna whack him over the head with that
giant hourglass of his it's inevitable
and i think it's gonna happen before
aaron rodgers calls it quits and i could
see aaron rodgers playing deeper
into his 40s than otherwise would have
if he ends up with another team just to
continue to stick it to the packers and
and rogers is what six years younger
so just that fact alone makes me think
that rogers will outlast brady and that
brady will retire first
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports